mona lives in a refugee camp in the
syrian province of idlib
every day with her friends she comes to
this landfill
she searches for plastic she can sell
for recycling
i come here every day to work and help
my father who is sick and can't work
i'm helping my father to buy some bread
because we left our area sinjar
and we have nothing but some clothes
after ten years of civil war syria's
economy
is in tatters in 2011 the currency
traded at 47 liras to the dollar
now it's at more than 1200. the un says
food prices tripled last year
and estimates four in five syrians now
live below the poverty line
this winter there has been a shortage of
fuel and wheat
we come here every morning scrapping
through leftovers and plastics to bring
back home
and sell to make a living sometimes we
find food and eat it
even give it to our children at home if
there's enough of it
[Music]
[Applause]
idlib is home to about 3 million syrians
displaced by the war
about half for children many here
abandoned their assets
use their savings to flee and are now
desperate for work
they have little buffer for an economic
downturn so there is a growing reliance
on child labour
we search for plastic iron and copper we
go to every car that comes and then
collect and sell what we can
so i can have enough money for my family
and return home
more than 30 refugee camps surround
adlibs landfill sites
those who scavenge here contract skin
and lung diseases
they've caught hepatitis three weeks ago
three children died after a landfill
collapsed on them
we are poor and don't have anything to
eat we struggle day and night working
with injured hands
breathing fumes from smoke and the waste
it's a lot of suffering
only to earn four dollars which is not
enough to cover the basics
like medicine for us or our children
the world food programme estimates more
than 9 million syrians suffer from food
insecurity
that's half the country and the highest
on record
the worst of the war may be over but the
fight for survival
goes on charlotte ballas al jazeera